what's up guys Samuel leaves here and in
this week's video I'm gonna be
interviewing a guy called John Rae bored
and he's 21 and I met him when he was 20
and he will never have to work again
when he finishes University just because
he's began his journey in property and a
lot of people ask me about how do I
start when I'm young so I thought I'd
just interview someone who's been
successful or being successful at a
young age so John welcome to the show
thank you thanks very much you're
looking great you've recently had a
haircut yeah it wasn't great before but
yeah it's looking good yeah awesome bro
so listen why don't you start off just
by telling us a little bit about your
background and how you stumbled into
property or across me so I do history of
Tommy going into my third year now of
the University of Sheffield as to the
history and politics it was at the end
of my first year that my dad bought a
small development project and he was
interested in or he basically said you
know for a summer job John you're gonna
go and work on this and I had no
interested property that kind of thing
at this point I want to go in on and do
law now from then on I kind of thought
how can i how can I help my dad by
looking for renovation projects you know
he would get a bit interesting at this
point that's when I that's when I found
your book and that then sort of
propelled me to into the idea of renting
now my dad and me had never even thought
about renting never been in either of
our minds so he was wanting to submit do
it up sell it yeah he was working a very
old school quite on profit yes yeah
definitely it was kind of like oh I
fancy doing property be not it wasn't
doing it professionally really so 20
years old you that was when we met
yes which was like maybe six months five
months ago whatever it was yes yeah at
that time
tell me about you dad then so you say
your dad is doing property development
on a very small scale kind of aspiring
to do yes lovely guy but I was very
skeptical about the crash course and all
that I think was it yes yes so my dad
had small projects going on he works
very hard he's a full time job and he
added small projects going on she's
full-time job he's a quantity surveyor
so he works in the building trade is
doing his full-time job and
trying to do small developments and he
basically felt that with regards to how
things are going we should finish the
small developments and then maybe
potentially have a look at HMOs you
didn't properly understand what they
were and you know how how profitable it
is that kind of thing
so from then on it's basically been just
not so much a problem or anything like
that but it's just been a progression a
challenge if you will push him forward
getting him around to the idea yeah now
when when we met you were saying my dad
oh he wants to do this close to home he
hates all these type of properties he
hates these strategies and he was very
he was for his ways yes and also you dad
he's not like a super wealthy man or
anything he's working but he's he's yeah
equity in the house yes yeah and stuff
like that so so we spoke and I said to
you my advice would be and I think if
you're a young person watching this this
could be for you too don't necessarily
miss what's in front of your nose
mmm because because it'd be very easy in
your situation to be like my dad's not
really interested and dad's got some
equity from a dozen interests in this
I'm 20 I'm gonna start from scratch
I'm gonna find joint venture partners
I'm gonna do lease option agreements but
actually we spoke and I said get dad
outside yes definitely definitely
I read that yes uh I mean my dad once
I've explained the principles to him and
you dragged into a crash course I got
into a crash course you know he went
through it and he once he understood it
much better he knew how committed I was
to the cause of doing it he has been
very very supportive so it has been like
and you don't even drive right now
no no I don't I don't drive them so
you're a student you living in a house
sure you don't drive how did you go from
that so okay having a dad who's a little
bit interested in development and do it
a few projects but but go from that's
because lots of people are parents that
I've got equity like some people might
say to you or people watching this video
oh well it's alright for you because you
are a daddy well some equity who gave
you a helping hand
but the thing is yes that was a massive
help of course but nobody's in Ireland
we or I'm where I am because people have
helped me no one's got to where they're
at completely independently of anyone
it's a case of saying
can I possibly joint venture with work
with who I can bring value to them they
can bring it out to me because a joint
venture is when you both bring equal
value to the table so how did you get
your downside and how does that
relationship look and what value did you
bring to him in order because I know
what happened he's basically said to you
as me
well you've set up a business together
yes fifty-fifty he puts in the money but
you worked really hard
yes it's cuz she's amazing it is it's
great work is my dad as well because me
it brought a lot closer together so it
has been great in that kind of sense for
our relationship but I I really enjoy
working with him I feel we both
complement each other I'm quite and I
don't really see problems I see them as
challenges and so I'm good at just
pressing forward and being determined
that kind of thing my dad is much better
if you know if there's problems with his
problems between people he's very good
at sorting out confrontations any kind
of problems what we might have with any
kind of state agents so we both
complement each other quite well yeah so
to anyone who's thinking of doing it
quite are you engage I would say as you
said you've got to look at what's in
front of you use things to your
advantage so obviously my dad had a
slight interest in development projects
and I've brought him on board and we're
working together now it's working well
but one of the ways I know some people
would say well it's alright for you but
you have to show an incredible amount
eat alright for you because your dad
might have some equity in his house that
kind thing but you have to show
incredible persistence to start with you
have to have a mindset that it's not a
problem
things are not problems they are only
challenges and they can be overcome yeah
so you've said things before about being
an aunt we're sort of you if you can't
go if something's blocking your path you
either get over it you know your way
through it or you go under it you don't
let things stop you so when you've got
that kind of mindset and especially this
helped my dad come on side when he could
see that there were no problems there
were only challenges and I would fought
fight through them then he became much
very supportive and thought we can do
this that's Brit and you know what
though when you have that kind of
philosophy and that kind of I'm an aunt
I'm going to get you through this and
I'm going to study what happens is you
students start attracting people mmm
definitely whether that be your parent
whether that be family members or you've
got those are people here going to do
business with you yeah definitely it's
so light I think that's awesome bro
so how do you need 21 now so I'll say 21
but when we met you were 20 so how do
you at 21 how do you some of you how do
you get that far in your belly how do
you get that that desire and that
passion and that confidence to really go
for it cuz you've got like deal multiple
deals going through at the moment yes
which is incredible so how do you have
the confidence and the more and setting
the resilience to do that um you just
you just have to you've got to have
something you got to have a reason why
so you said this before he got her I
think was in your book as well you got
to have that reason why now I want my
dad to he doesn't be what he wants to
potentially leave his job at some point
you know wants to be financially secure
I want that for him so he's given me a
lot in life so I would like to help him
massively as much as I can so that is
one of my reasons why I also want to set
up a secure future for myself which
isn't obviously another reason why and I
feel that although university is a path
and it's a lot of path a lot of people
go down and then they get a job and that
kind of thing that's great but I would
just prefer to do it another way so for
me I would like that passive income yeah
I'm also really interested in charity
work so I'm very interested in as you do
in Africa and obviously my trip to
Uganda with you was amazing so I could
I'd be interested in doing charity to it
like that at some point once I got a
good flow of passive income hopefully
we've less hopefully with less bedbugs
yeah hi hey books
that was funny that yes I was something
there to see it I was in the hospital
but Ugandan was incredible yes and then
you ended up we flew you back to South
Africa yes and you had a dinner with
Robert Kiyosaki
yes that was amazing thousand miles
which basically consisted of a bunch of
Academy members yes a handful of other
people and Robert Kiyosaki and these
other famous celebrities and invest yes
yes I mean geez how was that
it was amazing it was amazing and got to
asking loads of good questions he it
wasn't it wasn't massively specific on
certain things so I you know he was
quite varied so Robert you're talking
about Robert yeah so Robert would he
would discuss property quite a lot which
is on
what we as property investors are very
interested in what you would discuss
other things as well like you know
interests in sort of small stock
companies small companies so it gave me
an enlightened vision of okay this
property which is what I want my
foundation in yeah and this is what he
said
you have 95% of your wealth and assets
in safe stocks and safe things so
properties his and then he puts 5% in
other things what are perhaps more
volatile but you can have massive gains
so it was amazing speaking to the man
like find out his philosophy his reason
why but also his kind of basic
strategies he didn't go very massively
deep into the his specifics and mention
his specific thing companies than that
but learning his basic strategies and
wasted wasted is awesome I mean what
what do you in universities friends
think knowing that you're there having
dinner with Kiyosaki by multiple
properties yet you're never set up to
never have to work attained your life I
mean do they know I mean some of them do
some of them I have spoken to some of
them and it's more that some of them are
very supportive but it's a lack of
understanding of exactly what I'm doing
I am just sort of I'm doing something in
property it's not a hundred percent
understood exactly what but yeah people
people I had a guy yesterday come up to
me and say you know I hear you're a
property mogul and that kind of thing or
it's nice that people actually recognize
that's that's through your training
putting things on Facebook and sort of
trying to build my own brand people are
starting to recognize a little bit so
it's good people are supportive in the
majority have you know how do you deal
with people who are unsupportive and
people that say like you know are that
silly or who's you that you are or think
you're arrogant or people that hate rich
people I mean how do you deal it because
I'm sure you've come across that yes yes
I mean there is there is obviously that
kind of element but for me it's people
are gonna have their own opinion it's
it's not down to me to change their
opinion they can have whatever opinion
they want as long as I don't let it stop
me and it won't stop me I just keep
plowing on ya
there are obviously going to be people
who dislike what you're doing forever
political reasons or anything like that
but whatever belief reasons but you as
long as I'm true to myself and I'm doing
what I want to do and I'm doing it for
the reasons that I said in my reasons
why you know that benefit me and other
people then I'm completely fine with
them not agreeing with me and I'll just
go and do me effectively keep going and
when you join the Academy and we met at
the crash course I don't even remember
me saying but I said to you look your
dad has got equity and you're planning
on tapping into that yes but whether we
whether we partners with you or not
you're gonna be successful
remember we're saying that yes and I
said there's going to be other people
that I've got money that you can tap in
yes because when you become an
attractive person because you've got the
skills you've got the confidence the
knowledge then things will come to you
and you'll get joint venture partner so
I said don't Bank on you dad but yeah
here's the funny thing it you dad's done
you a favor in one sense but you've also
done you'd have a favor yes your dad was
had all these ideas to invest in
properties he didn't know he was doing
that much he was about to buy something
not great Robert cities yes
yeah and now you've come along I said
look I've joined the Academy I've done
to the crash course I've got a really
good mentor I know Robert Kiyosaki yes
like here's how we can invest so for him
he's even though he's only making 50%
now he's making 50% is still more than
he would have made if he'd have invested
himself in there and properties right
obviously it builds our relationship
makes a you know father-and-son
relationship makes it much stronger
which is good but when winning that
obviously I can help him become
financially free and I can push myself
and become financially free so it's
benefiting us both yeah it's yeah it's
great it's great that I've got my dad on
board and he's an awesome guy yeah here
now with us yeah yeah the program and he
supports you aids
it's so helpful to have family
supporting you what you do yes I mean I
think that everybody in their situation
they've got some things for them they've
got some things against them some people
watching this video say well I haven't
got a dad with equity in my house fine
well what have you got
yeah no that's what you had and you you
doubt some you dealt cards in life and
sometimes your help you doubt a good
hand sometimes you doubt a bad hand
but you've got to do the best you can do
with your cards and if either you've
done that at like 2021
I think it's incredible why don't you
just tell us a little bit I mean you've
under you could bat to compete on a
property this Friday yes yeah so tell me
the figures of this property so the
property were completing on and you're
very you're very good at your marketing
research yes you're very good with
numbers pretty conservative so just tell
us where it is what the figures aren't
stuff so properties in Burnley its
buying the property for seventy six
thousand and we're looking at probably
return of about fourteen hundred you
buying it for seventy six thousand how
on earth can you buy a house people
don't believe me that's why I have to go
and record people six months after
they've bought injured to prove it but
how can you buy a house for sixty sorry
seventy six grand and then rent it out
for like fourteen hundred pounds a month
that just doesn't make any sense
it's obviously setting up as a HMO
letting out the rooms individually we're
looking for blue-collar workers in this
specific you know this specific property
so people who might not have enough
money at the minute for to put down for
a mortgage and it's cheaper than buying
it getting a whole house themselves so
then if it's them but it's also more
profit for us we you and you bought it
by 76 are you confident that you'll be
able to rent it out room bottom a room
by room basis yeah definitely we've got
we've got a chair manager in the area
and everything like that so everything
he's done your research you've spoken to
investors you spoken to multiple agents
you're confident you've seen what about
the refurb how much is the reefer bit of
cost I think it's about three to four
grand we you know just ein now all the
small technicalities of it spiders and
things like nineteen thousand pound
deposit two thousand pounds for the
refurb a few thousand as for stomach
juices so we're talking like about 26
grand all-in yeah yeah 26:20 in rented
out of a fourteen hundred out of that
fourteen hundred how much of us profit I
think it's I think we've got about seven
or eight hundred profit so what have you
worked out so hold on let me work this
out right now live so if you're gonna
invest twenty six thousand
you're gonna make call it seven hundred
a month times 12 that's eight thousand
four hundred divide that by twenty six
grand that's giving you a thirty two
point three percent return on invest
which is that definitely deserves a
high-five yeah boom and of course you're
gonna do you're gonna do keep me posted
on how the deal goes yeah definitely
come
you know when it's rented out let me
know we can we can pop a bottle of
champagne but that but you've got
multiple properties going through it yes
yes and half of the profit you're
getting to keep yeah yeah definitely
yeah just for doing the work yeah but I
tell you what though if you're able to
find deals that good mm-hmm and you've
made all this happen
then I think you deserve half yeah
definitely what advice would you give to
other young 21 year olds don't let
anything stop you generally view things
what you might view things generally
it's a problem but if you don't views a
problem instead of you just as a
challenge even when you say I Chung's
what you mean is instead of saying oh no
that can't be done you saying oh uh
obstacle how do we get round yeah so you
might be Mike having a fear of talking
to sort of estate agents or something
like that and you feel they would take
you seriously because of your age if you
might view that as like a problem in a
sense but really if you view as a
challenge
oh it's a challenge to go and speak to
stage I'm worried they won't take me
seriously view as a challenge is easier
to overcome it and then you know I feel
I always think that if I view things as
challenges it's easier to overcome them
so like the aunt trying to get round
something yeah it's a challenge if you
as a problem you can have like a mind
block and just think I can't do it and
then you I let that bro what's it been
like working with me it's been brilliant
yeah so lots lots of lots of good events
mean DfE PPE all those kind of things is
give me a great amount of detailed
information from loads of different good
trainers and obviously including
yourself and the juror to yourself but
well thanks what do you think of the the
friends that you've made along the way
because I'm he's made a lot of good but
even what Alastair people like just a
lot of good friends I mean how's that be
James device yeah it's amazing so the
Academy you say from the stage you saw
appreciate is kind of like a family so
we all look out for each other and help
each other so like the for instance the
first pick meeting I went to and Martha
gave me a lift home back to Sheffield
and and mothers also yeah she was going
back up to Middlesbrough to realize also
financially for us yes yeah she's doing
great but it's just like kind of support
obviously I don't have a car I would
have been about three trains to get
I got back like 1 a.m. or something and
just a bit depressing really so she was
like Oh John yeah give you a hand and
brought me back the other night I stayed
and when I came to help on the crash
courses I stayed at Alistair's house he
was like oh you know I can help you out
and then I can drive you there in the
morning help you out I mean just having
friends with all these people that are
financially free yeah and the crazy
thing is your life right now you still
live in a new house sure I've just moved
into the accommodation for my third year
it's still a house yeah yeah yeah but
you're living in a house share and you
don't drive your life this appears to be
like a typical 21 year old yeah but it
isn't because you've got these
properties going up in value this cash
flow coming in which your honor you're
saving and you're putting other houses
so that when you leave uni in a year's
time
you never gonna have to work a day in
your life I mean it's not luxury but
it's freedom definitely yeah yeah we
just got to keep propelling it and your
heart is big and it's just a real
pleasure to meet you so thanks so much
John sorry you know what if you're
watching this and you've got questions
for John if you post below or I will
badger in to answer all the questions
and comments below on this video you're
for that yeah definitely so John's going
to be personally on this video watching
it answering the comments I will be as
well so John thanks for coming on the
show browser expose day yeah thank you
so much for watching if you benefited
from that video please do share it with
your family and friends for more videos
like it you can watch right here and if
you'd like to spend two days with me at
the property investors crash course
watch this video see what happens but
whatever you do don't forget to
subscribe right here and I'll see you
next time